So we've been talking the trusted
computing base, what it has to do.
The fact that it has to be small, but
it has to be sort of the kernel or
be at the center of everything,
isn't it.
We talked about,
it should do complete mediation.
You have to go through it to get
to physical hardware resources.
Or, we shouldn't be able to bypass it.
So that means this is something
you always go through and
this is at the hardware core
of any system that we have.
So, the Kernel is that core,
the inner-most.
The most trusted, hopefully
something that you can trust for
things to be right.
And this kernel is where the security
mechanisms have to be enforced.
So the security kernel is sort
of at the center or the core.
It has to enforce anything
to do with security.
The fact that all it's at the center and
small.
It's just a kernel, and
it's not everything,
an entire blob, hopefully that
helps with good isolation.
Small size is good for verifiability so
kernel design basically says look for
the smallest possible system where
you can put your security mechanisms.
The reference monitor that
controls access to objects
where all references are monitored.
Enforcement all security mechanisms
access to protected objects or
resources, one of those.
The reference monitor function
of course has to be wanted.
The security kernel has to address and
the security kernel
sends good isolation.
Actually, it becomes the core
of the trusted computing base or
the trusted computing base,
so it has to be tamper proof.
You shouldn't be able to bypass it,
always gets in the way,
it's always invoked.
That's our complete
mediation function or
reference monitor that has
to check every reference.
And going back to the small size we
had before, we want, the small size
is going to help us be able to analyze
it and understand it and make sure that
it does enforce or implement
the security mechanisms that we need.
And those implementations are correct.
So the idea here is that trusted
computing base, one approach is
the security kernel approach where you
bring the security relevant functions
together and that goes at the core of
the system that you're trying to build.